no
that's a jam i love that song wild any
song you want um i'll do bye bye bye
nsync
it doesn't have to be something you do
whatever anything
no like anything you want
back off my broccolini
get your life together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
happy new years boys first came here of
2022 buddy 22.
eric survived the the onslaught yeah man
omnicron yeah without freaking out or
what um it didn't freak me out because i
just felt like at this point
you know yeah you're going to get it or
you're not gonna get it i was annoyed
because it's like being fully vaccinated
and then you still get it
so now i'm like [ __ ] you you know what i
mean it's like if i go to a restaurant
and they're like hey we need to see your
vaccination why we can still get it you
can still get it you know what i mean i
guess it's just that's why you're more
likely to get it but then your vaccine
but the
supposedly the side effects like the
symptoms aren't supposed to be so bad
well that's when i think that places are
just they're worried about making sure
that you don't die at their place
are you vaccinated yeah because if
you're not they're like ain't gonna die
here yep but like i had like my symptoms
were like
the first night that so i knew i had it
i took the test and i was like oh [ __ ]
and that night i had like chills yeah
and i had a really bad headache you're
like shaking yeah it's just it was like
that was the worst of it and then the
next day i was having a little bit of
chest tightness so you know you google
[ __ ] and that's one of the ones where
you go go to the emergency room you
don't want to google anything i know but
i did but then i just took a couple of
tylenol and then that went away was the
headache there non-stop though that's
how mine was that was constant and it
was like here it was a foreign man-made
headache yeah i mean i had to get all
right
right here yeah i put an ice pack on
what do you mean by tightness so what do
you mean by tightness right well if you
have like chest tightness or pressure in
your chest
that's like a real
serious symptom but so but then it's
also uh when you get anxious you feel
that too so then when like you're
anxious because you think oh is this a
bad thing i don't know what was causing
it yeah was i just being like super but
anyway but you're fine now i'm fine it
was like then every single day after
that it was all increasingly better
better yeah you haven't had it right
stevie no i got pink eye
we want and we wanted to say hold up i
want to defend hold on i don't want to
defend myself because when i when i told
you guys you guys went to the fart jokes
it went straight to the fart jokes uh
who gets people
i'm a nasty dude i used to [ __ ] a black
butt i have flashlights so that's why
you went to the
what that's why we thought somebody
farted in your face yeah we thought you
were like no you thought you were like
going extra on a butthole yeah you know
what i mean
like you just
time stamped things like you just went
you know
are you just yeah but that scared me
because when i woke up i was no you know
what happened i was telling them before
i scared you well because i went to
spiderman with jeremiah that the night
before we went to spot it was packed
sure it was sold out like people in
outfits their spider-man outfits
but then i noticed we went to get korean
food after we got uh oxtails that's what
we got oh oxtail yeah oxtail soup and i
noticed like my eye was kind of like
itching and so i kept itching at it that
didn't help but that's the thing i woke
up the next morning and now that's the
picture i showed you guys
it would just like look like rocky
balboa like hit you
know maybe you didn't wash your hands
after uh you know touching that ox tail
yeah or you were like you didn't wipe
properly maybe a little bit got on your
finger yeah but then i it got to the
other eye
how long was this stevie
so i so once i i knew i had it because
i've had it as a kid i knew it was sure
conjunctivitis i went to the emerg the
clinic i went to the clinic first in my
neighborhood there's one in my
neighborhood went there i don't even
think homie was like a real doctor doc
like this russian dude i know that's why
you're there yeah he didn't i think he
was a nurse like yeah because
he didn't know you could tell
and then i go dude can you just
prescribe me the
so he gave me i got the drop yeah the
antibiotic and that
wasn't working i was i was following
directions
so i had to go back i went to cedars
i went to cedar the er and cedars
because it just was it packed in there
though with code patients dude i was
there for uh eight hours top minimum
right how did you know you went through
i i just know how to do that you went to
the emergency room yes yeah that's even
coke it was a nightmare no no how the
hell did you know that because my buddy
works
my friend's a nurse his him and his wife
they're nurses they've been nurses for
like 20 years now and they work at the
big county hospital and they're just
like telling me like it's just it's just
packed with non-vaccinated cover
patients that's the majority of people
that are in the hospital for that so
then you got people that got pink eye or
they break their leg or they no you're
waiting they're like they're like where
are those people it's annoying to me
that's what they should have some
warehouse downtown for like you know
just some warehouse downtown for
unvaccinated people and you go you all
got to go there to get your stuff
because the hospital is for people that
are like you know
digging in
the things i seen in there those eight
hours they should just have you're
saying they should have a hospital for
patients yes yeah vaccine or
non-vaccinate yeah no but i but i feel
like because you got vaccinated you
still got it i know but if you're like
my okay how about this though my
stepfather who is vaccinated got covet
but he has a pre-existing condition of
like asthma so he had to go to the
hospital to get on a
ventilate whatever they had to give him
oxygen and steroids you know so he did
everything he was supposed to do but he
figured 70 something so you know what i
mean you need it for those people and
then it's like but all these other
people who are just like i'm
anti-vaccine whatever and it's not gonna
affect me and then they get it and they
get super sick and they go into the
hospital where you're like hey this
could have been avoided could it though
i think the the part the goal to the
hospital part could have been avoided i
don't know man for some of these people
that was omicron
but who knows i know what's happening
i'm with you i don't know because i'm
pissed off too i was like
fully vaccinated and i got this now like
get boosters like for what you're now
with especially i was set to get my
booster that monday
okay i was gonna get the booster that
monday got this but now i got the real
booster
yeah yeah
yeah you got the real deal holy [ __ ]
and then rachel this is what pissed me
off too so rachel was like
she didn't get it at first you know and
you want them to get it
a little bit
but then but then when she as soon as
she like felt like oh my god my throat
all of a sudden she was like you need to
go to the store as if her kovac canceled
out my coffee yeah right so now i don't
got covet now her life's more important
yeah yeah she's fine you need to go to
the store bro i have a heartbreaking
story heartbreaking
so my kid's best friend has a cat i i
don't like cats i'm allergic yeah yeah
me too so my son's like dad want a cat
he's been harassing me for weeks get a
cat get a cat finally i do my research
i'm like i'm allergic to them so i need
a hypo allergenic cat so they don't shed
tough to get that's that ferrari money
right there
he was like ferrari or cat for my kid
yeah let's
yeah
so i go so i go online this is yesterday
oh so i go online i'm like i mean give
him a cat
research it there's a certain russian
blue cat that can get that's
hypoallergenic they look sweet
i get the picture of the cat show it to
my son he's all crowned kim and his him
and his mom go buy all the cat gear
they're there there's foxy oh is that a
real cat yeah so we got two so i bought
two of them i bought that one that's
cute and uh in a boy one the boy's
name's rip and her name's gonna be beth
from yellowstone look at the eyes so
beautiful my kids all crunk and uh and
uh what i uh the guys only text me right
because that's me he goes yeah man uh
we're based out of oklahoma
we're gonna ship the cow make sure make
sure somebody's home at 9 00 a.m
and in my head i'm like oh i've been in
oklahoma it's it's five o'clock like
how's the cat going to get here so
[ __ ] fast that's hope though maybe
they figured out whatever yeah keep
going my girl has the cats as a screen
saver she's sending pictures all her
family about my son we get my son's like
he's going to sleep with some illegal
[ __ ] about that so then i go so we
already bought one right i cashed out
the dude one right and then i go hey man
i feel bad having this cat be by itself
and i work a lot my girl will be there
with the kids but she'll probably have a
friend and he's like oh for sure man his
best friend is foxy and they'd sleep
together and all this stuff he sent me
pictures i'm like i'll take that too man
put both of them in there send me there
he's like yeah no prom man send me the
money like yeah sure dog send the money
send the money paypal another cash up
okay another hour goes like a hooker
yeah yeah that's what you say takes like
cash up or whatever credit card whatever
another outcome that should have been
your sign right there right now oh that
is a sketchy one huh ready for chapter
get ready yeah get ready for it another
hour goes by he goes hey man we're at
the uh we're at the airport and our
crate doesn't work so he needs the cats
need this special crate or they're going
to freeze death it's so cold out here oh
there's a hustle buy or two grand
and then when we're two grand then when
we drop the cat off we'll give you the
cash back and right there i'm like bing
so i call him and he picks the phone
goes hello
you're in oklahoma
uh yeah yeah oklahoma oklahoma cool man
uh now you you're based out of where
exactly in oklahoma because i've been
oklahoma a million times yeah stillwater
yes uh uh oklahoma state i'm like oh
oklahoma state that's still water
oklahoma he would have said stillwater
no no no he says stillwater he says
still water and that's that's why i
[ __ ] up he says stillwater and i'm
like oh cool man that's where oklahoma
state plays right the call where they're
the cowboys yeah yeah and he goes uh
yeah i go or is that or is that the
sooners no you're in the sooner land
oklahoma oh you're testing him yeah yeah
and he goes uh yeah yeah sooner sooner
they're like yeah that's right there's
soon all lie and he goes yeah yeah just
well but his english is terrible it's
why the money and i'm like ah [ __ ] i'm
out money so then i look up online scams
and this website's on there so one
second there's a picture of this cat
right
so once i once you've seen this cat all
cute after that yeah
but once i realized there's a scam i
read online they're going to try to keep
you talking keep you talking so i got
and my girl's like in shambles crying
and i started laughing i said ah you had
that kind of screen saver like
[ __ ]
and then so they're like they want to
keep you talking to get money out of you
so i'm like oh he's going to engage in
this and you already saw through his
[ __ ] but i didn't tell him yet i
know but you knew that i knew it all
right
you should have sent a picture of
yourself that's what i did so i sent him
a picture of a bengal tiger like a
[ __ ] big tiger hey bro i'm super into
cats man so those two what's the chance
you haven't find something like this in
oklahoma dog and he goes uh possible
possible no doubt dude that's gonna be
so much fun oh yeah
and he's like not responding and he goes
we can get it done i go for sure man i'm
sure the rules and regulations in
california super easy to get a bingo cat
on that plane and he goes two and he
puts too easy i'm like yeah say less so
then i [ __ ] with me more i can't get to
a picture of sick freaking roids uh
[ __ ] white tiger they go dude i want
up this ante i can't tell how much i
love i can't tell how much i love cats
man can you get me these so i need the
two cats already paid for the bengal
tiger and these two siberian white
tigers and he goes these might be tough
but we can figure it out i go dude just
tell me i'm gonna send money right now
how much for all this it was for those
who'd be like 12 grand go dude i'm going
to send this right now and he goes
congrats on your purchase blah blah blah
oh he's oh yeah
and then i go i'm just going to run it
by my uncle real quick he knows cat's
like a [ __ ] and i sent him a
picture of joe exotic with two [ __ ]
tigers he just didn't respond back so i
got hustled but bring up i want to
[ __ ] out this piece of [ __ ] so yeah
yeah yeah
you're out the money oh yeah oh yeah
they take your money so it was a whole
hustle i looked up on online on reddit
they say you can't get your money back
with with uh cash app you can report as
scam they look into it and they might
send my money back but uh so his number
is 405-293-8708
and his uh name on uh cash app is money
y26 z13 that's shipping our [ __ ] red
flag
brenden
brandon i like do a call by action what
do you want them to do to this squad
you sent money to a cash app name that
was just a number like that yeah well
are you sending money to the nigerian
lawyer too well i i don't out my girl
but i didn't deal with a lot of them
um
so the website is what is that bluebell
russianblues.com full complete scam
stole my money as a piece of [ __ ] yeah
they're pieces of [ __ ] and and they use
that uh vpn so you can't so i like
searched for all this [ __ ] the number
was actually in uh district of columbia
but it's a uh vpn so he's probably in
fact if he knew who you were he wouldn't
[ __ ] with you like that no if he knew
well he might have because they're like
an after somebody yeah there are no
places around they're not worried about
it they're usually like i said before
aggressive messages
um if anybody knows now my son is gonna
[ __ ]
cry himself to sleep i need two hyper
allergenic cats in la and i will drive
to you and pay extra if you have two
kittens two kittens yeah one hyper
allergy whatever they are but now people
are gonna be like well it's gonna be 3
500
and i'm going to extra spec
hey who hustles cats though yeah hustle
but that's a hustle but that's what i'm
live that i went online and apparently
cats and puppies especially like the
exotic ones is a big hustle dude geez it
happens all the [ __ ] time so she you
so yo hold on a second not to put her on
blast but we're gonna put her on blast
so the guy says the cash app the name
y26z13
and she was like okay
this seems about right she doesn't know
man she doesn't yeah man i'm sorry that
happened why don't you just get a dog
man i want a dog my girlfriend
this
that's the problem i'm so allergic to
him
but i went online dude there's so many
people have been [ __ ] scanned by
these [ __ ] i know it's crazy it's
insane he's making a lot of money doing
this think about it he hustled me for a
few hours made whatever season he was
probably rushing to do wait he was in
russia i talked to him you know what i
don't understand i don't i don't
understand if these things actually work
sometimes like snapchat like i'm about
to delete it because you got it because
snapchat you get these like you get
these messages like it'll be like some
random girl sends you a message right
and and it's starting it's like it's
friend request you know then you know
you'd be like all right whoever i don't
know who this is and then all of a
sudden they they'll send a message
all these nude photos and stuff and then
they'll be like you know
oh i'm looking for whatever and then
there's a website link and i'm like
broken english yeah in broken english
and i'm like do you does this work
like i always send them a message like
does this work do people actually think
you're real like what do you like you
know it's like you call them out yeah i
always call them out it's like i just
don't get it it's like every friend
request now it seems to be yeah
like billion billion dollar industry
billion dollar industry they're scamming
people left there's a lot of scams in
india too oh yeah a lot of people
a lot of if they're in africa i started
watching this guy he's got a youtube
channel it's called uh scammer payback
and he's like a he's like a hacker and
he somehow like gets information from
him and he finds out what building
they're in in india and he scares he's
like i'm watching you haresh i'm
watching you oh we're gonna find
yeah you should hire an expert to locate
this guy
i've been me i wanted to figure out a
way to incorporate there we go oh there
you go dude but it's real it's it's fun
because like the guys will get all
pissed off in india and they're like no
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
i don't know it's good stuff i just i
sometimes i just i feel bad when it's
like elderly people oh they take
advantage like i told my girl because
she was like i don't get how you're
upset i said because we're so fortunate
where i'll make a bid out of this it'll
be a great story on the podcast oh yeah
that's fine i'll make my money back off
taking myself for sure yeah yeah yeah
but that's fine
there's people out there where this
would [ __ ] crush them oh yeah that's
the problem all right when my when my
stepdad was in the hospital you know my
mom's got dementia so i'm at their place
sitting with my mom and their phone kept
ringing you know they got a house phone
still the phone kept ringing and it was
like every call was like oh hi we're
calling about your medicare yeah but all
this stuff and it was like six calls in
a row
where i'm like and i'm on the phone like
[ __ ] yeah
don't don't you [ __ ] call my parents
again you know i'm really gonna you they
hang up how do you get the info of you
because once you put your like nowadays
oh they sell that information put your
email or you put your phone number on so
many things and they're just calling and
calling
i mean it's so easy to tell have you
gotten those emails from it's a fake
apple it's like someone's broken your
account or instagram bank of america and
you click on the email and it's like yz
dayday
yeah bfa had one where it's like you're
you're getting text messages your
account is about to get suspended you
need to call this number now but i call
the bank first if you're like my mom's
age like she doesn't know she's like
damn my my my phone's getting turned off
i'm like mom first of all apple's not
gonna approach you like that no that or
the the big scam the b scam one of the
social security ones so no taxes yeah
right right yeah
does not call your house and ask for
money no that's not the way the
government works they'll mail you
something yes or they'll just take it
right out of your account or you'll know
trust me your car works but they call me
like hey everything okay there's not
gonna be some automated message but
press two no and then all of a sudden
you're talking to somebody like oh you
work for the irs jing bosh from what you
know what i mean
like who are you who the hell do you
work for the irs dude you work for the
eyes listen i don't know some sketchy
line all of a sudden i said dad though i
can't tell my son yeah your parents got
hustled on the [ __ ] internet dude no
you don't need to tell him well this
morning he said and dude i've never seen
him so excited for anything we're at jiu
jitsu he stops the class he's like i'm
getting two cats tomorrow morning their
neighbor rip and bath i'm like oh [ __ ]
by then i knew what was going on we got
to beat this guy down we got to be able
yeah let's get this find this guy but
he's in i'm not going to fly to africa
to beat his ass for the cats
fans in all these countries aren't
that's true yeah right nick
chin come on man
i like how nick the look on nick's face
is like
trying to put out a public head on
i'm just worried about my like this
morning he's like dad my cat's gonna be
when i get back oh hey buddy where there
come from in oklahoma the weather's
really bad so it might take you a little
longer so i'm hoping about this tomorrow
so
i'm trying to call him this is the
scammer you talk to him nick okay oh
he's calling the scammer let's take a
little break from the shenanigans with
the cats crew
because this podcast is sponsored by
better help better h-e-l-p
listen if there's something interfering
with their happiness it's 2022 man and
mental health is finally a thing people
are talking about it you don't have to
be embarrassed by it better help will
assess you with your needs all right and
they match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating under 48 hours it's not a
crisis line it's not self-help it's
professionals all right we got you man
it's done securely online all right the
service is available worldwide you can
log on your account anytime send a
message to your therapist let them know
it's what's going on in your life
you gotta quit talking your friends your
buddies you need professional help man
and these people really freaking help
it's much more affordable than
traditional offline therapy financial
aid is also available if you need it
better help once you start living a
happier life today we got you covered
man visit betterhelp.com kats that's
better h-e-l-p
and joined over 2 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the health
with their healthy healthy brains all
right and you need to be talking to a
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help they're
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states so a little special offer for
the king listeners and viewers get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
kats
i can hang out whatever i want
hello
fresh man that's right it's a new year
everybody including myself trying to
lose weight trying to get in shape maybe
run that thick mudder with me january
29th uh sign up for the thick boy at 10
am
you have a goal man whatever that goal
is you want to look better in clothes
you you got a wedding coming up you got
a freaking uh hot freaking holiday
coming up you have an anniversary coming
up you want to be in shape that better
help help you out man all right hello
fresh cuts back on time spent in the
kitchen so you can spend time with your
friends your family meals are writing
about 30 minutes or less plus it's quick
and easy including 20 minute recipes low
prep easy clean up we got you covered
man don't forget dessert either baby
although if you're trying to lose weight
forget it all right so uh hello fresh is
72 percent cheaper than restaurant meals
and the exact same quality man listen
dude over 65 bucks per month when you
order hellofresh instead of grocery
shopping that's how much you save man
that's more money to put towards those
other 2022 goals of yours
hellofresh offers 50 million market
items choose from every freaking week
whatever diet you're on veggie calorie
smart family friendly gourmet options we
got tons of variety we got you covered
man and hello fresh is super flexible
you can customize to whatever you're
trying to do online or in the app all
right easily change whatever meal that
you want you and listen go to
hellofresh.com king16 use the code king
16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts all right that's
hellofresh.com king 16.
all right hello fresh america's number
one meal kit i love it
can the scammer here eric uh
did you block your number say you're
looking for cats it's google voice okay
say you're looking for cats
he's not just gonna answer
hi you've reached one four zero five two
nine three eight seven zero eight
messages please leave your message after
the tone
hey what's up uh i'm looking for a
hypoallergenic cat uh
uh my son's really excited about it i
was told you or the guys um i've got
like 2 500 to spend if that will do it
for us if you give me a call back my
number is
what is my number
give me email
email me at
cats r us
you should have planned this out i
should have planned it out i'm bailing
out nick we need my scammer
do it one more time and i'll feed you
the number
do it one more time i couldn't find my
google voice number i got your number
okay i got it even the scammers like
this is scary
[Laughter]
for a podcast right now
dude one more time nick we got you back
i'm worried about brendan's son right
now
who's like
this [ __ ] this game is gonna listen
to this and be like we gotta get this
guy's cats and [ __ ] tiger shows up at
my [ __ ]
two bengal tigers he must have been
thinking like for a second like oh i got
a good one yeah
he was like oh i got we got one you know
i sent him like [ __ ] big ass tiger
like 700 pound tiger so in total you're
out what two grand yeah yeah yeah
but that's still two grand man oh that's
super frustrating it's the principal he
needs to pay for that oh we could have
got a better bonus
so you out here
waste everybody no cats
now trust me
but it did not i do about nine other
shows and i own that network
you out here wasting money on cats
i know some groceries brandon
i need grocery money baby yeah stevie
over here stealing red
[ __ ] about
the fans who are wondering where theo
was at get that video still made a nice
little video for all the cats fans
hyper allergenic feel every day can we
get all the hypoallergenic cats fans
outside
what's up cats
uh
gang baby
it's the rk son you know uh
welcome to 2022 um
what's going on just want to wish
everybody a happy new years uh
i'm just
um i got this
i'm at my aunt's house i got this soap
so
pretty nice from them gift
oh
it's head and body it's a
dual bar or whatever they
call it but um
anyway i just wanted to wish everybody a
happy new year's and say that uh i won't
be seeing you guys until
uh february
um i'm just gonna
take a
slower entry into 2022
take some time for myself here at the
beginning of the year
um
and uh
yeah i just wanted to let you know so
you heard it from me um
[Music]
yeah brandon i'm grateful to brandon i'm
grateful to you guys
uh i'm grateful to nick
um i'm grateful to eric father time
um
and that beautiful little booty dolphin
you know what i'm talking about
uh
uh
so
yeah they'll all be holding it down and
i'll see you guys in february um
but yeah i want to i just want to say
also i love you and thank you so much
for uh for your support of of king and
the sting
and uh and your support of me
and uh happy new years
and um gang gang baby buzz buzz but you
know what i'm saying
gang gang really
that's the video you would play on a
commercial that was like for 99 cents a
month yeah you can help this one and
then you get scammed
yeah zoom in every other every other
other week maybe no he's not you're not
going to zoom in but cat listeners and
viewers don't worry we have a special
get we have we're going to have special
guests dropping in and then stevie eric
myself will be constant here through
january and theo's going to hit the
ground running in february so don't
sweat it man
and here's the thing with deal i love
him like a brother
you guys don't you know theo deals with
some demons man and he's been running
hard in the paint for yeah i realized
like he's been doing stand up for 14
years and then you know has had recent
success and it's a lot formats a lot
with his um you know demons that he has
so what's what is his schedule's too
overbooked or something he's just a
different animal like you know for him
if he works a lot it wears them out and
creates anxiety and you know certain
issues for me i'm the opposite yeah if i
don't work i get like that you're going
through so we're the opposite right i
mean him well at least he didn't like
you know take off his shirt like antonio
brown and just leave us like this bye
[Applause]
health that's all this is okay to keep
up the support support theo
and uh yeah that's all it is man no
biggie
uh this guy's got a question for us for
the cat's crew so kingstein crews
brendan theo
stevie and eric nick and jean what's up
everybody
the new year is coming up
um kind of i don't know if it's a debate
club or whatever but
just kind of interested to see what you
guys new year resolutions are going to
be
i think mine's going to be um
[Music]
getting out there putting myself out
there more in the dating game yeah
let's help this guy out
get myself right so
yeah i'm going to put myself out there a
little bit more put yourself out there
on cats my real estate license because
i'm down here in fort myers florida
good market here from colorado
great place but yeah let me know what
you guys new year's resolutions are
going to be and um i like this
yeah so i hope you guys had a beautiful
christmas you guys are awesome i love
you guys it's a nice game what you're
doing
we could help them out in the dating
game real estate
yeah i mean because i tried to get mark
harley sending a video and followed up
with he said he was going to you
followed up with him yesterday didn't
get back to me but uh i'm on him we'll
give you yeah yeah
but we should definitely reach out to
that guy give him some dates new year's
resolutions uh let's start with stevie
what do you got eating less buttholes
yeah
um
master cutting down on my masturbation
just cutting back yeah like how many
times we're talking a week
every night
so seven times a week yeah
maybe cut down a is there any anymore do
you have any two a days you're doing any
two days i don't do tuesday
no no two days no training camp days
that and then
what was that brendan no training camp
days them two days
i'm gonna see steve do it like a like a
workout jack off video yeah really
secondary guys you get your baby oil
where are you where are you for me this
whole episode you're actually doing very
korean brother those are my support
tools
are you gonna cut down like four a week
now yeah maybe four weeks and then
you keep it through my sleeping schedule
you need better sleep i feel like you
sleep a ton no no like though my hours
of sleep consistency consistency like
you want to be in bed at certain times
yeah
those are the main things they're good
yeah i like it eric did you make uh
resolutions yeah i have the old corny
one but i just i i just got a rowing
machine one of those hydro rowing
machines
scammed on instagram you know one of
those welcomed the club yeah baby but it
was i cash after them
and then um yeah so i've been doing like
i did it this morning before i came here
that's dope when you came in it might be
covered could be the new workout machine
he looks thinner but i'm trying dude and
then i might like
yeah i gotta
really
feel that i gotta feel it yeah
we need a splash of racism in here
without theo thank you thank you thank
you that was like a mist of racism
yeah so i'm really trying to like stick
with this regiment you know for you man
uh because i'm getting gonna get married
this year so i want to like
congratulations you want to look your
best yeah i want to try to look my best
and you've got kids yeah we talked about
we are we invited the wedding
that i'm going to get addresses
uh jen nick any new year's resolutions
uh just uh work harder on the off days i
feel like i kind of plateaued in 2021
just uh i mean works good but off days
meaning the weekends i think less
gambling would have been better for you
that ain't bad i'm going to turn
gambling i'm going to turn gambling
profitable by doing gambling content
that's my plan and i'm gonna help you
with that hell yeah yeah oh good idea
yeah like that show on fox fox bet yeah
but those guys are dumbasses uh jim what
do you got i have a bunch actually oh
you're one of those guys yeah but i've
already started down and [ __ ] no i just
i just knew what i wanted to do so i
already started before the new year so
some weird deals nah nothing weird
getting my neck healthier you're right i
have like a picture thing
shot tomorrow but i'm constantly doing
it yes i'm working on my neck uh getting
in better shape drinking less ooh and
i've already met like i've already
reduced my creative intake i've been
taking every day so i'll take it twice a
day now i used to do like six times a
day
but there's nothing wrong with it
people you know benefit from i just but
it's just something like i don't rely on
something about yeah
and then
i don't know what you're talking about
that that that powder that i take all
the time you see anything
oh
it's called happy hippo kratom oh no
i've known about them for a long time
yeah
but so that also helped
you like a drug dealer
uh build thick boy to be as big as
possible that's a huge huge goal and
i'll obviously my own youtube channel i
want to just put more content out all
right yeah
i love that there you go i love that
you got you guys should be doing
something we already think we're asian
we're both asian hey [ __ ] you always go
in there yeah exactly
you're backing up i knew it now he's
like where's my circle i love this guy
he's a good guy
a piece of [ __ ] he's looking for asian
supporters
stevie had me on the show like a long
time ago yeah yeah cb has i don't know i
have total support uh uh you're on
youtube you're always welcome and you
know it let's go to christian and kyle
[Laughter]
the young bucks new year's resolutions
you're going to grow this year honestly
one is the same as chains and that's to
build dick boy to be the best that it is
isn't it like 13 grand to get oil change
for that no not at all it's under
warranty oh yeah 13 grand yeah that's
what i uh
the bugatti's though because it's tough
to get to the bay so you literally have
to pull the whole chassis out god damn i
think we got 13 then to change the tires
i think it's like 25 grand a tire on a
bugatti if you've got ferrari money you
got to like you don't have bugatti money
but what i'm saying though is like if
you you can't just be like oh i got a
ferrari you got to have like maintenance
yeah you gotta have maintenance this is
christian's time i'm sorry i'm sorry
sorry christian you guys are good you
guys are good
another thing i have is uh we're in
italian
in italian okay
learn jujitsu in mma and that's it
jiu jitsu an italian
[Laughter]
uh yeah i actually mastered the basics
in duolingo so far i don't say mastered
though that day that's what duolingo
says all right well um
uh but uh my news resolutions thank you
guys um i'm glad you asked
no i don't i really don't have any i'm
on a diet but i'm always on a diet but
i'm gonna die because i'm running the
tough mudder i think it's january 20
what is that what is that it's tough
mudder it's like a 10 10 mile uh like
obstacle course obstacle course
so i'm trying to get down probably like
10 12 pounds before the 29th oh this is
like that's why i started that's such a
rich guy new year's resolution you know
it's kind of like well you know i'm
gonna lose weight that was yours dawg
yeah
yeah but i i i'm doing a rowing machine
you doing some kind of exotic mud
wrestling
i hate to be shitty about it
i ain't being shitty about i'm already
in shape you know what i'm saying so
it's like
like extra
i want people to do it get in shape they
can do the diet or just the healthy
lifestyle of the 29th you go to a tough
mudder now there's a thick boy race on
there's the 10 a.m one callan's doing it
mark harley chappelle
casey we have the whole crew doing it
man so cool i'm not there yet
eric i promise you you could do it huh
well maybe i promise you let's we would
try it out
i'm telling you there's a time limit is
there a time limit this guy this is not
a good angle of this video for this guy
it's just this is yours
dude no he looks like dana white when
he's talking [ __ ] to jake paul the same
angle but uh george sent in his uh new
year's resolution
my boy george
bro yeah i think look at him he's gonna
disappear he looks great yeah he's gonna
disappear you're too skinny now we like
george a little fat right
eric's db
theo
oh
i'm trying to lose 10 pounds
classes
and thanks to you guys i'm having a
[ __ ] beautiful year really
um
but i wanted to say happy new years to
all you guys
and i got a pretty big new year's
resolution and i want to hear what you
guys think
me
you guys the boys in the back
i want us all to hit the booty club
let's all go to the strip club together
i heard you're talking on alabama's
episode about your time
just let me know i am there i think it
would be amazing i've never been i got
nobody let's go get something let's get
it
i am in chicago in uh march that's where
he's from
dude we should do a dating show with
george
it's not a bad idea
nick the problem is always getting
female suitors regardless of the guy but
i'm down together
she's a special guy we should definitely
do it for george and that first guy and
for mark harley so we have a bunch of
contestants
but the other thing is i had this girl
come the
show and dania
and she was
i forget her name
it was a state it might have been her
name might have been alabama no it's
georgia
i told her damn nick
dime peace
and she wants to be honest she's like i
can beat alabama but i'm like they don't
fight oh georgia
yeah you should i don't know if george
her vibe i feel you i like where your
head's at yeah when you see her though
come on dude it might be you're being
very nice yes i like how you beat listen
will sweet listen we love george i love
drawing my favorite he's still working
on it okay she she's she's this this
girl is bad super hottie let's see if
can we see a picture of her yeah if i
can find it yeah how bad like hot like
playmate model yeah you might not
finish your
new year's resolution when you see yeah
like you see it yeah you're gonna be
like from seven days i'm back to seven
days i'm about to
let me see it
i don't know your flavor but yeah my
flavor's weird his flavor yeah steve
flavor is female and breathing is she a
grandmother
all right should we get in another
debate club i'll find her
in the meantime
up from the lsd lower slower delaware
is james coming what's
baby got a debate club for you
pittsburgh michigan state outside the
stands by the concessions got a couple
fellas duking it out one gentleman
counter punches almost knocks his wife
out she's rolling around the ground
other fella does a little dancing
kiss punch
not a good look either so debate club
who should be more embarrassed by this
[ __ ] let me know gang gang eyes buzz
and next time take your take your
retainer out
his teeth are formed a certain way you
don't send in a video you know what i
mean let's see this let's
this is uh eight million views oh one's
big oh dude look at this
is this antonio brown versus oh push
them in the face
the guy who got pushed he starts acting
like just a clown he's all [ __ ] look at
him oh
shooting free throws and [ __ ] put your
hands on me
oh oh oh
oh oh did he hit a girl
she just really got knocked over and
then she was super dramatic about it and
that's his wife
not sure exactly
but the big guy was trying to break it
up though now you're telling me not one
of them white boys dropped an n word
throughout this whole video that might
have been what started who knows but
then they get into it again what's going
on here and who wins this the white boy
took him down it was really just an
embarrassing fight all the all around
that looks like i'm more worried about
the cholesterol the big guy trying to
break it up
because
it was a good build-up yeah i was really
excited like yeah
he was like this
oh yeah he's grabbing his hair oh that's
oh come on
oh another guy's holding him oh but the
other guy's trying to break it up and
hold him
oh he's got his hair damn
i don't understand are they going to
kiss he seems like the black guy is lost
i'm more embarrassed
for both of them really why is he being
why is the black guy the one being
surrounded and held down well that guy
has his back is trying to just control
him so they didn't fight and then that
white guy they did attack each other
here and
the black guy went for a double leg
and he just got sat on basically
yeah i guess sprawled out
okay
yeah god they really can't fight yeah
this is the public and whoever the video
person is is like can you like next time
don't stand behind the fact look at the
ass crap when you're like look at that i
know you know you don't want to be
behind the fat guy when you're filming i
mean i'm embarrassed for all of you yeah
so i'm more concerned about the health
of the fat guys you know this isn't one
of these things it's like
most people just don't know how to fight
not at all you know it's just
you know what i mean like what do you
like what are you doing there
what started it nick
we don't know oh no oh
the whole thing is like if you want to
here's the thing who
did did this guy in the blue shirt
initially hit yeah that guy is either
one he pushes his face okay so this is
my thing you're gonna push a guy in his
face why are you standing behind your
woman now like you initiated a fight get
her out of the way well she's kind of in
the middle of she's getting you know
what you're about to do yeah you see
this guy you know
her out of the way we get him going
put her out of the way oh that's why
because the black just going for a punch
punching him at that time
athletic yeah
that punch is so it's so they're both
terrible crap
and she falls
she didn't get hit though no she's about
juicing she's so powerful she's not she
like you know
so what was the question
who
i think
when the people don't know how to fight
just let them go like yeah let them get
it out of their system whatever happens
you know the average street fight lasts
like 40 seconds nobody has any stamina
nobody knows you've been like they just
all bravado you know one time i was like
uh i was i remember just well i was
living at this place and like there was
there was kids outside
and i knew one of the kids he lived in
the building you know and he was
surrounded by like four dudes and they
were like you know on him you know and
so i came outside and said what the hell
y'all doing you know and then you know
they were like well he's talking [ __ ]
whatever and i was like all right so you
want to fight him i said everybody else
back up
so everybody else back up because this
is a guy because it looks like four on
one right now yeah which ain't cool yeah
it's not cool all right so if you want
to fight let's let's see what's gonna
happen now yeah you know and then it
just it just de-escalated
you know everybody was like you know man
you know [ __ ] you dude [ __ ] you old
yeah yeah yeah man you're so tough you
know it's just
ugh
i don't know
those people are both dumbasses yeah the
thing you gotta worry about in a street
fight is like you'll see somebody like
cold [ __ ] somebody and when they hit
their head on the ground like people go
to prison all the time no but dude but
isn't it like you have no idea assault
assault but isn't it like when somebody
really can't fight
they're never like that's the person
that's gonna be the most level head yeah
correct you know what i mean
you you know when you mess it with
somebody you're not supposed to be yeah
they're a little too calm yeah yeah yeah
they've been there before yeah man
all right this guy's got a king
understand it for us
what up king in this thing young bucks
here come from appleton wisconsin
mia 190 nick
[ __ ] [ __ ]
for you guys
what do you guys think about it
on your bedroom
so i got did he michael jordan over
there
and then my brother's name because it
was his room but
what do you guys think about it at least
i had my
if own guys would then what would you
guys put let me know oh i don't mind it
i i think i know you don't mind it steve
hey that's not cool man
oh i got your back what are you supposed
to what do you mean by that steve i have
stickers in my room it's different
i have stickers right guys yeah that's
so different
it's different it is i think that vibe
it's cool
whatever yeah
that's when you live with your parents
still this guy get attacked by a shark
or what maybe he'll
sharks murdering these fish
are you in the restaurants with the
humans ordering fish let me know what
you think gang gang
dang he got one
oh
oh he didn't even get it oh no he gets
it right here that's that big boy he had
on the leash
that fish like what the [ __ ] this is
great footage nick
yeah wow look at him
i don't mind it dude dude i just saw a
video of a girl
in a suit like that swimming with a
great white that's some white that's
different that's just choose why you
don't oh come on
come on with white people but just like
i mean i'm talking about a huge 25 foot
yeah they're great white and she's just
swimming along and like you know you
just see that you know bro here's the
thing with spare fishing so when you
spare the fish they bleed right so then
sharks
spare fishers get [ __ ] bit all the
time they do yeah because the blood
comes out of the water and then the
sharks like oh there's an injured fish
we're going to go over there and they
see your big dumb white ass [ __ ]
fish
but sharks don't really want to attack
human beings oh yeah i love when experts
say that
just sit down don't you watch shark week
that's my favorite week on national
geographic i love it too but here's the
thing with shark week like yeah i need
some new content
i just can't see a great white jump out
of the water no stop over a seal like
you got to mix some [ __ ] up so forward
or against it i mean cause that changes
it what you just said i i mean i i'm not
gonna do it but if you want to do it
i'm at the restaurant yeah i'm at the
restaurant
you know what i'm saying
with a soup appetizer i'm getting yeah
have you heard of crabbing catching crab
yeah well that's how you got pink guy
crabbing
time stamp
everybody's going to hate me you know
what can i say something
i i like making myself laugh it's the
reason why i say things sure i don't
give a [ __ ] about you guys
like look at my face i don't give a [ __ ]
about you
i make jokes for me in the comments
again
the eric just making jokes to make
himself laugh yeah [ __ ] yeah
i think it's funny yeah so i know that's
gonna be one of those moments you know
never like eric's bullying stevie man
i've never done any i didn't cry i've
never crabbed or fished like that i used
fish all the time when i was younger
what sort of asian are you
here we go yeah even chin fishes i do i
like spear fishing spear fishing i kind
of don't like i love fishing but spear
fishing feels just way more brutal like
you want to catch a fish oh knock it out
right away a metal hook through their
mouth what would you rather have a
spirit through your body or a hook
through your mouth would be nothing i
don't
no but also fish you know they attack
with their mouths their mouths they have
like way more like cartilage whatever
they're in the body i just for me it
doesn't feel right yeah that's super
humid and then when you get it onto the
boat what do you do with it so i don't
let it yeah yeah so a lot of people just
let it you know just suffer no you do
you kill it yeah i have a little taste a
little bat and i make sure you just
dispatch it no just a couple times on
the head this is he learned this from
his gang
so stevie let me ask you this would you
rather be have a hook through the mouth
and then they pull you out of bed and
then beat you to death
how about this
how about this just die right away with
like boost
you struggle
i see your point they don't die right
away no but also so the whole hitting
the head would you rather be knocked out
and then people do [ __ ] to your body or
would you have just cut through your
body as you're alive
when you're knocked out you know what's
going on can i tell you something all
these are horrible
but if you had to choose would you drive
this beautiful way to die i wouldn't
want to be pulled by my mouth
like you know
so you'd rather have a spear go through
your body and still be alive yeah
come on
they're both they're both terrible
what's the other option there's a third
option oh the neck but they're very
internet but things yeah i think it's
hard to rather get caught in a net
that'd be terrible you still gotta kill
you still gotta kill it though i want
like forrest gump to catch me in a
shrimp boat yeah yeah you know a lot of
people just throw in the boat and let
them suffocate that i don't want to do
that so i just knock them up let's say
well first of all listen listen yeah
listen
you don't think you're better
than the others
cereal yeah i'm saying you're for me
yeah i might be one but i eat fish so i
have to you know i feel like if i eat
fish levels like you don't think the
fish is going to be like you know what i
think i want to die by chin's hands yeah
i bet you a fish could talk they would
rather have mai the other way i would
dispatch him be like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah die anyways that's fishing day
oh yeah you think i don't want to go
fishing
so we're going to a strip club yeah yeah
let's go we're going to buy a hypogenic
cat we're just throwing ideas out there
you know at eric's bachelor party we go
fishing fishing
i'm down let's do it and then we go
abroad and find that scammer and beat
them up yeah good [ __ ] bathroom what
a weekend yeah yes
now we have to get six round trip
tickets to africa
biscuit and everybody gets massages yeah
what's the balcony what is the book uh
the the girl she said she gives massages
people on yachts
i liked her
call back
[Laughter]
fun reception
all right here we go
hi guys my name is angelica i'm from
chicago and i have a request for you
guys i really enjoyed watching the best
of 2021 video it was so funny but my
favorite part was when you guys did the
karaoke so if you could do it again
that'd be so awesome thanks
oh
okay and we do have this like set up and
i have a way so we won't get demonetized
all right who i don't know who wants to
go first but we can we don't want air
going first yeah yeah he's gonna crush
it i got like a serious thing
who won last time i forgot who won who
won i definitely won i didn't
enter the sand man oh yeah what if i
don't know these songs you will uh
they're pretty they're pretty common on
there and if you get the wild then you
get to pick whatever song you'd like and
and then uh you're gonna bring the
lyrics up here yep and then who's gonna
how are we gonna play the music uh it's
gonna be in your headphones oh and then
we're just singing yeah in the final mix
it's gonna sound like acapella oh oh
okay
we're gonna sound like pure [ __ ] yeah
but i think i think i sound terrible i
think it'll be great i'll get this [ __ ]
off
big money
purple rain i hate i hate i don't like
prince
whoops
no
that's a jan i love that song wild any
song you want um i'll do bye bye bye
nsync uh you it doesn't have to be
something else
anything
no like anything you want
i do bye-bye yeah it does that because
it's got to be that pass on the ball
story
you have the other uh mic if you want to
hold it just uh feel a little bit more
karaoke all right here oh yeah okay that
sounds nice you want to move the others
no effects on it
if you go to a bar you don't get effects
we're not in there yes you do really
yeah karaoke places yeah
i love chin's like oh i just thought
yeah
yeah they do but yeah yeah and you could
adjust it again
next time we'll do it i figured if you
went to a bar it's just like that's why
it's like if you're a bad singer no they
put like chorus on it yeah they put a
little put a little reverb reverb yeah
the thick one
bye bye
i'm doing this tonight you're probably
gonna start a fight i know this can't be
right hey baby come on
i loved you endlessly and you weren't
there for me so now it's time to leave
and make it alone
i know that i can't take no more it
ain't no lie
i wanna see you out that door baby bye
bye
cause you maybe hate me but it ain't no
lie baby bye bye bye
the shitty manager that was scamming
them
you see what [ __ ] happens you african
scammers
all right eric you're next i'm gonna
make millions off you guys reselling
yeah keep all the money go ahead eric
okay grief
it's it's the guy that apparently i
can't
i don't know it's like it's good to be
back
what is this wild so any song you want
doesn't have to be on the wheel if you
don't want oh we got dave matthews i
picked a lot of your hits on there
though uh bits or the ones that you said
you wanted like purple rain
purple rain's my jam all right
oh he's gonna kill this he's gonna end
it right here again you're gonna you're
gonna end it i can't sing yeah you can
oh he's that guy yeah yes you are
give me that thing
purple rain we know i would never oh my
god don't make me do this it's
embarrassing
guys you're embarrassing me i would
never know how to can you move the other
mic out of the oh it's just too much
just yeah
i think we're good all right
look at steve's looking for a good
korean jam oh [ __ ]
do some bts baby is that is that racist
yeah it is dude let me choose fire
it's fire transgender men but it's fire
doug
it's eric's time
it's gonna be back at cats 2022
this is a weird mix of it yeah it is
do you want a different one no that's
fine i don't care
i never meant to cause you and his
sorrow
ain't this a [ __ ]
i never meant to call you any pain
i only want not to see you laughing
you know i feel like [ __ ]
i only wanted to see you laughing in the
purple rain purple rain
purple rain
i'm about to [ __ ] kyle
purple rain
purple rain
purple rainbow
[Music]
i only wanted to see you bathing in the
purple rain
never want to be your
weekend lover
take notes christian cow i think we're
good now right
yeah
what do you want
no you got an eric one you really gotta
put the effects on it it changes the
whole thing
we'll have to do it again but stevie has
to sing a song okay i'll spin the wheel
for me yeah uh okay uh bts
k-pop
ah purple rain again let me spin that
[ __ ] yeah
wild
shinano connor nothing compares to you
okay
you sure you don't want tlc waterproof
no no no no no no i'll just do this one
okay
we'll be your backups okay thank you
yeah mainly when i say we i mean eric
can't hear it oh
it's been seven hours and fifteen
days
[Music]
i go out every night and sleep all day
since you took your love away
you ain't gonna cry
since you've been gone like you do well
whenever
i could eat my dinner in a fancy korean
okay mr nothing compares to you
[Music]
it's been so lonely without you
here
your sadness
nothing can stop these lonely tears from
falling
so tell me baby
where did i go wrong
i could put my arms around every boy i
see okay
let's get to the course one more
that's
time
guys's part
i went to the doctor and guess what he
told me what to tell you what he told me
what did he do he said girl you better
try to have fun no matter when what you
do but he's a fool doctor's trying to
[ __ ] nothing compares
nothing compares to you
god who hurt her
that's a prince the pulp thanks for
tuning in that's actually the king of
the stage song
yeah episode 147. stupid talented that
was fun yeah prince wrote that so next
time effects yes well i came in last
year steve killed that that was all
steve right now no don't do that now you
know you won but you two can sing man no
[ __ ] my voice is all there right now all
right
that was a fun episode right guys that
was good it's good times okay we should
add chin play too
i don't think it'd be fair bro sorry so
on the docket we got to do a dating game
with a couple people yeah and we got to
try to get this scam can we do it with
kyle and christina
kyle or christian send us a video let us
know a little bit about yourself or if
there's any other guys you've seen on
the show uh some of the guys have lost
the dating game we gotta get mark harley
on here yeah mark george on this show we
never cleared up what we didn't clear up
if that guy was a fake
what what remember the guy like
the guy that had the beard and then the
picture was another guy they're not the
same guy he looked like yeah it wasn't
the same guy i think nick messed up some
places yeah so there were two there were
two patrick's right who submitted videos
who both had
uh like the the huge beard like that and
so we played the one video who was a
different guy than the guy we brought on
live [ __ ] but the guy who we
brought on live who also had the charles
manson beard he sent a picture of him
without the beard and he was like a
really
good looking handsome handsome right i
saw that but then it wasn't the same guy
yeah it wasn't guys
i'm pretty sure alabama has been in
contact with both of those fellas
both patrick's
nick you're single aren't you uh yeah
let's do one with you
i'm good i'm good
thanks all night man
because he gets he goes through the
videos
and sees all these monsters
think about that all the girls we've had
play uh be the contestants have been
really
that georgia girl's diamond dime you
didn't show me the picture yet of the uh
the
the one you're talking about
i couldn't find it was it all right
is that it nick that's it all right kids
uh as you're listening this i will be on
stage in raleigh north carolina rally
improv this thursday friday saturday
and
that's about it for january stand up um
that's about it for james stamp in
february i will be in uh salt lake city
wise guys and also sacramento at the
punch line so get your tickets at
fatkz.com also thick boy if you used to
watch me on below the belt food truck
diaries cowbest fight club it's all
under one thing it's thinkboy.com and if
you want ad free of all the shows i do
subscribe right now to the super cast
where we have classic fight companions
this week i'm breaking down my fights
next next week on breakdown fights with
a very fun fighter uh those are classic
fight campaigns so that's
that thing were you doing your fights
yeah that's dope yeah that's this week
the first
calabasas classic fight companion well
i'm going to be in michigan yes thank
you nick
january 8th scissor bros live at seoul
joel's in jeffersonville pennsylvania
get your tickets today this saturday
thank you nick you're welcome
nice stevie they're doing it and i'm
going to be in michigan uh the 13th at
park theater and then the 14th at this
place called the creston brewery so look
for me there what part of michigan
like grand rapids would be fun yeah
grand rapids and then i'm in edmonton at
the house of comedy on the 20th unless
canada changes their restrictions yeah
yep all right kids love you theo miss
you bro love you theo
[Music]
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin
brendan yeah you know how we do it so
just tune in for the laughs theo said
that he was on his way but ran out of
gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
now he only finished boys in the hallway
[Music]
just walked in and got it lit you can't
forget about brendan he still need
everything dick dick they still got the
bees and the trap trapping still the
king and the sting so quit asking if you
know then you know it's a cat's thing
ball and chain hair swang like the
raccoon king and the stink
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan theo too yeah you
know how we do it so just tune in for
the laughs theo said that he was on his
way but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting